[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much it's a pleasure and
an honor to be here and we all look
forward very much to the discussion that
we are about to have our speaker today
is mr. Roger Beaujolais he tells me that
I should introduce him by saying that
for 27 years he has been active in
mechanical design and structural
engineering in the aerospace industry he
has worked for some 14 companies of
which at least one you must be familiar
with and he did not mention this but I
will
in 1988 the American Association for the
Advancement of science awarded him the
prize for ethical behavior as a result
of his activities which followed the
Challenger accident that most of you are
familiar with he will talk to us about
engineering ethics constructive
responses to difficult situations and we
have asked a number of friends and
colleagues to comment on his remarks and
to give their testify to their
experience bear witness with their
experiences in issues of this sort we
have three panelists miss Freda Klein
who is the president of client
associates a consulting firm which deals
with which advises corporations on the
ways in which one adjusts in an ethical
and proper way relationships between
employees and the employers professor
Melcher who is a professor of Electrical
Engineering and computer science and he
has been active in electrostatics and a
number of other interesting fields he
has also been active in worrying about
the role the connection between the
academic community and and the Strategic
Defense Initiative and thinking about
this has brought home to him a number of
questions that we all need to worry
about and professor David marks who is
the professor of and head of the civil
engineering department and his region
his area of activity is environmental
engineering and management and control
primarily the public sector thereof
which raises again a substantial number
of interesting ethical questions I think
the way to proceed is going to be for
mr. Beaujolais to give us his remarks we
will then let the panelists make their
comments and then have a general
discussion mr. Beaujolais we are honored
to hear from you
thank you very much
this talk is based on my 27 years
experience in the aerospace industry at
14 companies I'm going to recommend to
you some of the methods I use to secure
a productive and satisfying career I
will suggest how to select your
entry-level employer explain the task of
getting settled in a new position and
how to recognize and deal with real
organizational trouble I will give you
some examples of my career
confrontations with lessons learned and
summarize with a few challenges to you
how to select your entry-level employer
that's what I'll deal with first seek
employment with a company that has a
large commercial mix of business rather
than a government dependent military or
aerospace base there are two reasons for
this first a mixed commercial business
even if combined with some government
business will provide a better
opportunity for long term stability and
second the company is more likely to be
responsive to conduct business on a
higher ethical plane due to the inherent
commercial marketplace accountability
that exists commercial marketplace
accountability has the effect of placing
business placing management at business
risk for future of their company as
opposed to a government contracted
company that essentially has zero
business risk or accountability even if
caught conducting unethical or
fraudulent business practices the
evidence to support this condition of
bounds in the media with many examples
of wrongdoing by many of the government
contractors without any of them ever
losing their contract to certification
to bid on those contracts their fines
after being caught are almost laughable
if it weren't for the seriousness of the
situation since they are delivering
faulty hardware that doesn't come close
to meeting specifications and are having
huge profits without accountability
an ideal company has approximately 1,000
employees reporting to one general
manager at one physical location this
number is not cast in concrete but is a
good starting point this size limitation
is very important since it it determines
how well a company or division can be
managed as well as its operating
philosophy read the book titled in
search of excellence for a detailed
rationale of why this size limitation is
important my 27 years experience mirrors
the position stated in that book and I
heartily subscribe to the small size
family type atmosphere organization that
provides the best career opportunity and
environment over all others interviews
especially at the entry level seem
totally one-sided with the company doing
its best to sell itself in their
organization that their organization
offers the best opportunity for a
professional career their one-sided
simply because students generally allow
it to become one-sided for fear of not
obtaining a job in a good-quality
interview and this is quite normal but
you have an obligation to yourself to
ascertain more about a company than they
will just tell you you must attempt to
find out about their management
philosophy and organizational structure
so you can evaluate if they match your
minimum ideals for example ask to whom
the quality control manager reports also
ask if they have a none busman program
and to whom that Ombudsman reports the
answers to these two questions alone
will provide great insight to their
management and operating philosophy they
will not guarantee anything but it will
provide significant insight for example
if neither the quality control manager
or the Ombudsman reports to the top
executive at that facility then this is
a red flag of caution because this may
be a deliberate management flaw in the
organization to promote the ability of
other line organizations to extract
cooperation with their agender by
intimidation of the quality control
manager or the EM buds Minh
and I can tell you as a side light if
the unbuttoned reports that a personnel
department that's two red flags of
caution I assure you that this type of
management organization creates the
ideal climate for unethical misuse of
wine organization power to meet the
goals of short-term profits and delivery
schedules and keep top management
segregated from the real day-to-day
operations but very happy with the
results provided another important
question to ask is does a top executive
hold at least a yearly meeting to give a
sort of state of the company status
review to its employees well-managed
companies generally tend towards this
type of communication from the top is a
very motivating time and the results are
usually recognized by these companies
that do it I believe that the most
important request you can make doing any
interview is to ask to speak in private
to your future peer group in the
departments which you are being
considered for employment and ask the
following questions as a minimum what do
you like or dislike about this company
would you recommend coming work here at
this time do you like working in this
department or would you prefer working
in another department is your supervisor
and manager a strong but supportive and
fair individual are you required to work
excessive overtime with or without
compensation at the whim of supervision
whether it is needed or not you will be
amazed at the candid answers that you
will receive but be sure to talk to more
than one person to minimize the
possibility of talking only to a
disgruntled employee also be prepared to
answer some questions about why you are
asking such questions I hope you have
concluded by now that all this requires
some detailed preparation so you can
present yourself in a smooth relaxed and
sincere manner practice with your fellow
job seeking peers and always remember
that companies are seeking the best
employees for their organizations and
you have your talents to offer in
exchange for a good ethical work
environment and career opportunity I
sincerely believe that many companies
have come full circle and realized that
their employee
are their number-one asset and they've
completed or in the process of shedding
their former business as usual mode of
operation in favor of organizational
changes which will provide open
objective discussion of problems now
that you've had an itch ants to get a
entry-level position let's talk about
the task of getting settled in that
profession that you've selected
companies generally use two methods to
introduce you to their organization one
is to assign you to read what seems to
be a never-ending stack of promises and
procedures manuals and the other is to
give you a short synopsis of the
contents of those manuals and assign an
informal mentor who will help you get
acquainted with their procedures if you
are unlucky enough to get the formal
method then a word of advice is
appropriate don't waste your time
reading that in detail because the
day-to-day operations of almost every
company has no resemblance to what's
written in the manuals be an attentive
observer of who in how things get done
and take every opportunity to attend
meetings and ask to do so if not invited
to do so you can assess so you can
assess the players quickly at first be
happy with your role as observer and be
attentive to who is participating in the
discussions identify the managers and
who is controlling the meeting and if
the discussions appear to be objective
with factual depth or just bland
rhetoric it is very important to assess
as quickly as possible
if meeting content is almost totally
controlled by management or if technical
subordinates are allowed to engage in
wide open discussion of problems one
surefire way to make this assessment is
to observe the person with the highest
authority at any meeting if that person
is usually quiet until near the end of
the meeting then it means he is truly
interested in problem resolution but if
that person usually speaks first about
technical content then he is using the
meeting for his own personal agenda and
little meaningful problem resolution
discussion will ensue spend as much time
as possible outside your assigned area
talking with people from other
departments
and soliciting their help in offering
yours be sincere about this because it
will become a very important asset for
you in the future
I used this very method to develop name
competency and productivity recognition
by others especially those in management
positions and this was a key element for
me in any organization with the sole
exception of being in the right place at
the right time with the right mentor and
that never happened to me don't ever be
afraid to speak out in support of a
technical position you have confidence
with but also don't be afraid to say I
don't know the answer to that question
instead of trying to bluff an answer to
and lose your precious integrity which
will result in long-term damage to your
career it will take approximately six to
nine months to feel comfortable within
the organization and then it is time to
start the serious documentation of your
work product by writing memos which are
carefully prepared to catch the eye of
your peers and management all mammals
must contain three basic features first
the subject of the memo must be clear
and concise it sounds very simple but
often time this is one of the most
brutalized aspect of the medal of a memo
second the memo must contain a complete
executive summary stating the problem
solution recommendations in a conclusion
in a maximum of one page I don't mean
the executive summary + introduction
spills over into the second page one
physical page is the maximum that an
executive summary should be contained in
never spill to the second page ever
third the detailed discussion containing
a much expanded version of the executive
summary with all the supporting data
deemed necessary to complete the
documentation of your work output this
memo format is very important because it
lets you send it to upper management
within and outside your department with
a high probability that they will read
the short executive summary in a in the
whole memo if the executive summary
piques their interest I highly recommend
the methods stated thus far but only
only and I emphasize only if you are
genuinely interested in receiving
recognition and are willing to
participate in
accelerated and increased portion of
productivity output now that we're
settled how do we go about spotting real
and serious organizational trouble and
what to do about it you will learn from
experience that very few projects run
smooth and trouble-free regardless of
the amount of talent assembled to solve
the problems because people always have
different levels of ego competence
self-esteem etc I define real trouble as
a recognized efficiency in a product
which has a reasonable probability of
causing a serious problem to the
end-user but is not acknowledged by
management to be a serious problem that
needs fixing the mode of operation that
usually precedes this definition is one
that I have already mentioned when the
person with the highest level Authority
controls the technical meetings and also
exercises absolute control on how
presentations are prepared and presented
both internally into customers this type
of organizational misconduct places the
technical professional in a very
difficult position between the company
management and the customer especially
when the technical people are expected
to defend management position whether
technically correct or not another clue
to look for is the lack of personal
recognition for exceptionally good work
in a high level of productivity at merit
review time this is usually a subtle but
highly visible message being sent to you
by someone in management that you do not
fit their definition of a team player if
you receive two non deserved bad merit
reviews in a row this is more than a
subtle suggestion of your fall from
favor with the hierarchy this is one of
the least adversarial and most effective
management tools used to crush a
person's ethical fiber and is used often
as a tool to encourage people to leave
voluntarily the most serious trouble of
all comes when meeting schedules
supersedes everything else especially
the requirements of safety and quality
this is the toughest category of serious
trouble to contest because shipments
produce revenue which maintains
short-term profits
keep executive management very happy
indeed be advised that there is no way
for an individual to ever win a forced
change of operation in this category of
trouble without committing sure and
Swift and career suicide
unless you are able to gather colleagues
support for your position if technical
support is received from your colleagues
then attempt to obtain their backing and
cooperation and meet with management to
discuss the problem and propose solution
you have a loyalty to the company you
work for to first seek problem
resolution through your organizational
chain of command don't ever go outside
without first giving them a chance to
correct the situation if management is
not receptive then attempt to publish a
position paper with the support of many
caught as many colleagues as possible
and send it up through the management
organization you may find that when you
put things on paper some of that support
will diminish if management also rejects
this approach it has now becomes
personal decision time and three
distinct options exist which are most
effectively stated in Albert Hirschman
book titled exit voice and loyalty at
this point of confrontation the
individual decisions are tough because
your career and peace of mind are at
stake I cannot tell you what to do but I
can assure you of an intense struggle
from within and difficulty with restless
sleep if you are a person of conscience
I do have some advice that should be
falled if you decide decide to write
memos like I did at Morton Thiokol in
1985 you must first gather all the
written evidence possible in the form of
memos reports drawings etc to support
your position and transport them to a
safe place away from the company or your
home prior to writing your first memo
the serious memo writing can now
commence and should inform management in
a clear and simple language about your
concerns so management cannot excuse me
claim at a misunderstanding at a later
date I was very lucky at Morton Thiokol
that my files were not purged by the
company before I had an opportunity to
give my information to the Presidential
Commission investigating the space
shuttle Challenger disaster I've thought
long and hard about the methods I use to
expose the truth about Challenger and I
have concluded that I would do
everything the same except I would
protect all the documentation well in
advance to avoid a lack of evidence at a
later date
now I'd like to share some personal
examples of my Korea confrontations the
following examples are in chronological
order to demonstrate how the magnitude
of confrontations increase in both
severity and frequency with years of
experience 1960 I was at my first job at
Hamilton standard in Broad Brook
Connecticut
a project engineer was reviewing a
rather extensive set of gear train
actuated calculations with me and I
noticed an error in an equation right at
the very beginning of the calculation
but said nothing and let him continue as
time passed I could no longer contain
myself and I blurted out that the
results were wrong due to an error at
the beginning of the analysis he was
shocked and quickly challenged me to
show him the error and he became angry
with me so I apologized him for the
delay and acknowledging that error he
composed himself quickly since he was
not angry for me for finding the error
but angry that I took so long to inform
him of it we became somewhat friendly
after this encounter the lesson I
learned from this was to never delay
bringing up bad news to anyone
because the delay causes more discord
and really throws an immense amount of
suspicion on your integrity in 1963 I
was at my third job at our automatics in
California I was hired to perform stress
analysis with the title of design
engineer and subsequently attempted to
obtain a transfer to the official
structures group to enhance my analysis
opportunities and capabilities but my
supervisor denied the request to
transfer upon hearing of layoffs and
witnessing those layoffs taken place at
the company of approximately 40,000
people at that division at the time I
immediately sought a position at another
company because I feared that my request
for transfer had damaged my relationship
with that supervisor I accepted another
position and submitted my wreck my
resignation and my supervisor was
shocked and he tried very very hard to
convince me to stay but I told him I had
already agreed and gave my word and I
I left the Western I learned was to
always participate in open discussion
about your position especially if you
feel it's in jeopardy in the example I
just gave before accepting other
employee I was very happy there but I
thought I didn't stand a prayer of of
staying there with those massive layoffs
that were coming on and just don't make
the mistakes that I've made in 1965 had
found myself my 6th job at Hamilton's
standard aerospace division totally
different division a different physical
location although it was the same
corporation my position was design
engineer and the Apollo lunar lander
environmental control system and I
refused to sign off on a discrepant part
as I was being pressured by a project
engineer to do so a Quality Control
Manager had observed the confrontation
and he approached me afterwards with
support and the following advice he told
me to ask myself the following question
when faced with a tough decision of
whether a product was acceptable and on
would you allow your wife or children to
use the product without any reservations
if I could not answer that question with
an unqualified yes he said I should not
sign off on that product for others to
use I have always used this as a
surefire method to defuse an ethical
dilemma concerning a safety of a product
and I've realized that it's really a
direct application and simple
application of the golden rule do unto
others as you would have them do unto
you
lesson learn was to always practice
personal and professional ethical
behavior and you go far in your career
for doing so in the 1967 273 timeframe I
was at my 8th job at a company called
Celeste go industry it was formerly a
West Coast defense division of Atlantic
research corporation that had been spun
off to Susquehanna as a senior stress
engineer I was selected as the
engineering representative to inspect
the Assembly of several Athena missiles
at the launch pad to assure compliance
to structural design requirements during
one of my inspections I found a pic
cable payload cable retention bolt was
loaded and bending across his threads
which is a no-no due to improperly
aligned mounting surfaces the failure of
this boat would destroy the nose cone
and ruin all chances for a successful
research and development flight so I
reported my concerns to the project
project
was my recommendation to replace the
hardware with properly designed surfaces
he refused to take action for fear of
delaying the launch so I told him that I
would call the airforce Colonel myself
and report my findings and he knew I
meant it so he placed the call the Air
Force agreed with me and immediately
obtained a high-priority work
authorization at a local machine shop
and the work was completed during the
weekend without delaying the launch the
colonel thanked me and I eventually
received company support because the
customer was pleased with my performance
another incident on the same program at
a later date involved a design mistake
in a tongue and groove joint on a heat
shield which continually failed in
testing a customer interface meeting was
convened to discuss the problem and as
the discussion continued for several
hours I discovered what the cause of the
problem was
while tinkering with several small parts
on my lap I was confident with my
findings and frustrated with the
superficial level of a problem
discussion which was wasting everyone's
time and I remember thinking that no one
wanted to say I'd do anything
significant because it was Friday
afternoon and to bring up a problem at
that late day would mean we'd probably
have to work through the weekend from
sheer frustration about my time being
wasted and knowing that I was going to
be the one working on a problem anyways
I spoke up and interrupted the meeting
used a simple demonstration with the
parts to show it was wrong and suggested
how to fix it I was right we worked the
weekend but we fixed the design and
we're back by testing by mid week and it
worked just fine
my immediate supervision was very
pleased with my efforts but the chief
engineer was not pleased at all for me
exposing the problem at the meeting in
front of the customer approximately a
year later the same chief engineer tried
in vain to order me to give a slanted
technical presentation to the air force
on the same missile structure I refused
to do so and the chief engineer gave the
presentation himself with me in the room
knowing full well that if I was asked
any detailed questions about my analysis
that I would have shot him down in
flames I have never seen anybody sweat
so much in all my life is that man did
during his presentation I'm positive
that that confrontation and refusal
make that presentation cost me a
supervisor's position at a later date
because he knew he could not manipulate
me as he was accustomed to doing with
others lessons learned from these
experiences that Celestia was the
opportunity to practice past lessons
learned and to reinforce my ethical
professional behavior in 1977 I found
myself at my 11th job at Garrity
Research in Torrance California while
working as a contract engineer and some
of you may know that term as a job
shopper where a company actually shops
you in to a parent company that needs
some temporary expert help while going
in there as a contract engineer I
discovered after approximately one month
that a structural beam designed to
support a 50,000 pound heat exchanger
would fail and lateral instability if
loaded during assembly and could cause
loss of life to those that were involved
in the assembling I was aware that the
equipment had been designed and analyzed
during the preceding 1 and a half years
by engineers with advanced degrees and
was in the final detail drawing phase
prior to fabrication I told my
supervisor about my analysis predicting
failure but he was somewhat skeptical
and so I thought oh no here I go again
another confrontation I arrived for work
the next day and had barely sat down at
my desk when my supervisor asked me to
go with him to the chief engineer's
office
I was surprised and initially pleased to
find that the prior evening they had
built a balsa wood beam scale-model beam
but disappointed to learn that his
purpose was to prove me the outside are
wrong we loaded the beam in the lab and
plotted deflection versus load curves as
the beam was incrementally loaded and as
soon as the critical load was reached
the beam started to roll and deflect
laterally much to the astonishment of my
supervisor in chief engineer they
quickly asked me for my recommendations
for fixing the beam and I responded the
fix was simply to place a closure plate
on the open side of the beam on the
compression side and this would prevent
the lateral instability action from
occurring a strip of balsa wood
simulating that closure plate was glued
in place and allowed to dry the beam was
again loaded in the same
load sequence as before to approximately
twice the world without any signs of
lateral instability
I was thanked for finding and correcting
the problem in about a week later
offered a chance to go work direct for
Garrett corporation after my contract
expired with the job shop the offer of
direct employment is very significant to
this example in experience since the
engineering department was primarily
composed of PhDs with only a few holding
master's degrees and to my knowledge no
one in the engineering department had a
Bachelor of Science degree when I went
to personnel with my completed
application form and resume and has to
be processed into the company the man
became very upset about three things
first according to him I had held ten
jobs before and he called me a transient
employee second he scoffed at me for
having a Bachelor of Science degree and
third there was no outstanding
requisition in the engineering
department for a new hire he told me
point blank that had I applied for
employment through the front door my
resume would have been swiftly discarded
without any chance of getting an
interview at that point I began to
resent his attitude towards me and told
him to either process me in or I would
directly or I would return to the chief
engineer and tell him he was abusing me
and since he didn't want and I assumed
he didn't want me to do that after my
statement he never spoke another word
and I probably hold the record for the
shortest time to process a new hire
ended Garrett corporation lessons
learned from this action was that the
good guys do win occasionally when
managers have the courage to listen and
act upon the facts and they did even
though they were trying to prove me
wrong they at least listened and took
the time to find out if there was
something wrong and the other lessons I
learned is job shopping is an absolutely
fantastic way to find a job but you can
only do that after you have about five
years experience unfortunately enjoy
1980 I found myself my fourteenth and
planned last industrial job at Morton
Thiokol this was planned to be my
retirement position since we moved to a
beautiful but rather remote area of
northern Utah he didn't work for that
in engineering you didn't work at all it
was that simple the major point I want
to convey to you is my conduct on the
job predating my deep involvement with
the escalation of the space shuttle
boosted joint touring problems I
conducted myself as I had always done in
the past and I soon found myself
involved in many of that caused problems
both on and off the shuttle program I
talked with many people about known
problems and provided recommendations
for Hardware modifications process
changes quality inspection techniques
analysis methods and so forth but I
meant with totally unexpected resistance
and was told straight out that they all
know best how to do things since they
have been doing it the same way for 20
years
I sometimes replied from pure
frustration that their methods were
based on two years experience multiplied
ten times and that they were 20 years
behind the rest of the industrialized
world since no one will listen to my
verbal recommendations I started writing
memos and followed the same procedures I
have already outlined for you I soon
became recognized by management as a
doer and became somewhat of a resident
expert on fasteners material selection
ground support equipment and failure
analysis so managers outside the shuttle
program sought my help with their
problems my relationship with in the
shuttle program still remain somewhat
adversarial especially with the director
of the engineering department I'd gone
to that director many many times with
good recommendations which he
acknowledged as good but then he always
took the business-as-usual side against
me approximately three and a half years
into that mode of operation I was given
a promotion to project engineering
manager on the shuttle booster case
structure this is very significant
because I leapt over several supervisors
who had been with I call over 20 years
and it demonstrates that the principles
of professionalism and ethical conduct
that I've been explaining to you can
indeed be rewarded I hope this makes
that my personal experiences
demonstrates to all of you both within
and outside of engineering that a
rewarding career is possible to attain
within the framework of ethical
professional
even when employed by organizations that
conduct themselves in a somewhat
unethical manner remember as long as
management can use your expertise and
still control their overall agenda there
is little danger of serious retribution
unless you pin them in a corner like I
did during the Challenger investigation
I also hope you realize that all your
future decisions will primarily be based
upon the character of your previous
decisions of small and relatively
unimportant matters during your careers
up to that point by way of example and
with absolutely no intent towards malice
I wasn't surprised when the vice
president of engineering at Morton
Thiokol capitulated to the general
managers directive to take off his
engineering hat and put on his
management hat at the meeting prior to
the challenge of launch I had observed
this man in several different
organizational positions for five and
1/2 years conduct himself in a manner to
always side with the business as usual
management philosophy I wasn't surprised
but I sure as hell was angry with him
for not standing up for what he knew was
technically correct as evidenced by his
own conclusions and recommendations
chart that he presented in the first
part of that telecon my closing remarks
are very simple I import all of you who
are pursuing engineering careers to
please set a goal and take and pass the
engineering and training exam prior to
graduation then after five years of
engineering experience take the PE exam
and become a licensed professional
engineer whether your chosen field
requires it or not I do not say these
things lightly I did it the hard way
30 years out of school last October I
took the EIT exam on Thursday and the PE
exam on Friday and if I can do it and I
passed them at this institution with the
quality of education you're getting you
it ought to be a piece of cake for you
people join and become an active
participant in a professional society
and start a movement to change the
societies towards support for their
members as opposed to supporting the
industry agenda of using employees as a
renewable resource
please don't join the business-as-usual
gang and always remember you have three
choices exit voice and loyalty but I
hope you won't subjectively chose
loyalty to preserve your status quo
thank you very much
[Applause]
they will have brief remarks from each
of the panelists and then we'll have
open discussion and there's that there
are mics on the floor our first speaker
will be free decline I want to comment
on a few of the things that Roger talked
about in terms of how do we evaluate a
company's ethical practice and this
approaches to ethical issues I think he
focused on issues of related to safety
related to health relate related to
possible dire consequences for the end
user I think there are also other kinds
of ethical dilemmas that arise in day to
day work lives of scientists and
engineers some of those have to do with
how employees are treated and how
employees treat each other as well there
are two categories of ethical issues
that I think are important to
distinguish one is ethical issues which
are those of omission where information
is left out or where people or where
groups are excluded and the other would
be ethical issues which are commissioned
where they're actual fraud or problems
committed when looking at a company I
think Rogers point about looking at
where the QC manager reports and whether
or not there's an Ombuds is a very
important and where they report there
ought to also be an array of complaint
mechanisms there ought to be formal
complaint mechanisms that have a
peer-review component and there ought to
be informal complaint structures that
assure confidentiality I think it's also
worth asking about the folklore what are
people rewarded for in that organization
who are the heroes who are the heroines
what are the heroic acts in recent
memory in the organization will tell you
a lot about what
valued if there's an open-door policy
for example many IBM employees will tell
you that the open door hits you in the
rear on the way out one local high tech
company has a phrase well known amongst
its employees called CLM s career
limiting moves any place has part of an
informal culture that will tell you
about its values and those are worth
finding out before signing on thank you
very much Peter all right Jim would you
like to speak Jimmy Melton electrical
engineer yes I'm not sure I have so much
in mind here giving any kind of
presentation so much as asking some
questions I had the good fortune
yesterday of spending a couple of hours
in Carolyn's home with Roger and I'd
like to I think maybe get some reactions
from you on some points one of these has
to do with the continued theme that came
across of your pride and your
professionalism your ability to be a
good engineer let me put this in our
context in this room in a faculty
meeting last spring I guess now we had a
wide-ranging debate on the subject of
pass/fail and you could imagine this is
a grading system for freshmen and it has
all sorts of sides to it but you would
find that perhaps half of the
engineering community was very much in
favor of seeing it drop they regarded it
as a mechanism of compromising the
expertise of our students now out of
that I would gather they probably didn't
succeed really in making their point but
that the point was as I saw it that if a
person were going to take a strong
position as you have many times it had
to be based on being very good at what
you did you gather feel somewhat along
those lines
I guess the best thing I can use as an
example when I filed my lawsuits against
Morton Thiokol they came down on me very
very hard trying to discredit me in
every possible manner that you can
imagine and my simple answer to some of
the things to counter their whole
activity was simply say then it must be
a horrible reflection on them because I
was within $1,000 of doubling my salary
between 1980 in the summer of 1986 and
so I rested in my case I said if I was a
lousy engineer a disgruntled engineer
and know-nothing engineer and what does
that make them for doubling my salary
and I also have to add to that I went
through school with a solid C not that
I'm proud of that if I had to do it all
over again I'd do it much differently
but I had a very high level of interest
in playing tennis skiing and playing
hockey
and I did do my very best to keep my
grades going but I did not hit my stride
and hit the Dean's List until my senior
year and as a result when you've already
had two years of solid C work it's very
hard to prick pick up your grade point
average and I probably wouldn't be
allowed in most universities today if
I'd done that same type of thing today
but it doesn't the grades and I in I
dressed this relative tee of pass/fail
comments the grades don't necessarily
mean you're gonna be a good engineer
grades don't necessarily mean you're
gonna be a person of integrity to speak
up and do what's right and I use myself
as his example I have had no trouble
whatsoever I graduated from Lowell
Technological Institute had 168 credit
hours of course study and where most of
my fellow students coming out of the
other universities have between 125 and
35 and I've never had any problem
whatsoever facing up and matching up
across the industry with anybody and
I'll tell you straight out there's a lot
of theoretical stuff I can't solve but I
let the guys with the pH D's do that
there's a lot of things they can't do in
putting a product out the door either
but I can do that so together we can put
out a heck of a prod
and that's what it really takes it takes
both types of people to really integrate
and make a company go and put out a
fantastic part let me try and get a bit
more of the sharing of the experiences
you've been through maybe following a
different direction you perhaps could
make an analogy to some of the
situations that you've had with
something I saw in 60 minutes
this last Sunday some of you may have
seen this they were interviewing people
whose children had essentially drowned
and then recovered because doctors had
done a little bit too good a job and
then been permanently unable to function
and they were interviewing a couple of
the mothers who were in crucial roles in
this and looking back these were mothers
who blamed in a way the doctor for
having kept their child alive when in
retrospect they would have preferred
really albeit a wrenching thing that the
child have been allowed to die now we
make it sound as though this decision
process for example the one you went
through and only a few days around the
Challenger incident was a very logical
progression and I would imagine that
there are events in there where you were
reacting just reacting that you were
drawing upon these previous experiences
you mentioned but and your religion your
ethical view of things which I wish we
could find some way for you to share
with us more but that there were also
moments contemplative moments when
probably you realized what the
consequences were consequences again
that aren't as black and white as we've
been talking about consequences of
walking the halls in your company and
finding that there were people who
wouldn't speak to you the man was the
mayor of a small community and in fact
found that he was essentially shunned in
the Mormon sense by the community these
are very personal things and there must
have been some point as this thing began
to evolve that you contemplated what you
were getting into and thought about ways
that you could keep your own values and
deal with this
and then took the course you did is that
true yeah but it probably didn't happen
as soon in the process as you might have
thought what happened was from my past
experiences and that's why I emphasized
it in in the previous remarks I was to
sum total of how I acted up to that
point in and it was just natural for me
to continue to do what I had always done
and I did not think of anything up until
the point that I got the the vilest
looks that you can imagine from the
general managers a general manager in in
his associate but particularly the
general manager and myself and Adi
Thompson compared those looks afterwards
and those are the looks we decided to
get just prior to being fired
now Arnie was quiet and I was quiet at
that point because there was no way that
we could interject ourselves into that
management meeting in the caucus so
that's the first little indication the
the the next major thing that happened
we just went on a failure investigation
team and we're doing our very best to
find out what happened and do it very
best to participate in the redesign but
the night before we were going to
testify to the Presidential Commission
and closed doors was the height of the
whole thing when I realized that I was
about to place myself right up to my
nostrils in quicksand because I wrote I
had written in my notebook a whole
summary of things that I was going to
relate to the Presidential Commission
and at the end of that I said something
to the effect and this is in the
National Archives and as a public record
but I have to paraphrase because I
haven't looked at it a long time said
something to the effect that I hope and
pray that what I'm about to do is not
going to ruin my career my lifestyle and
my family and then signed it and dated
it and so that's the first time right
there that I knew I was about to plunge
myself into a potential very high
retribution area but I still went ahead
and did it and I in even afterwards even
was the anguish from management received
on plane back to the Marshall Space
Flight Center I still felt even with
that that I still had a chance to
participate because I was being told I
was going to have that
to participate in a redesign I was very
naive but I truly believed it on my
heart and I felt that oh I may have cost
myself a raise or I'm a cost myself
something here or there
it didn't matter as long as I was able
to participate in fixing the problem I
was very happy with what I had done and
I'd do it again and then of course later
on I found out that that was not to be
be the case they had actually given the
official word behind my back to keep me
isolated from Morton thought from the
customer and the redesign effort
although I was a technical participator
in giving in information into the system
they would never tell me where it went
they changed it sometimes without my
knowledge they were holding meetings
that I didn't know occurred and I got
zero feedback so they did in fact
isolate me and when I discovered that I
realized just how deep a quicksand I was
in at that point in time and then in May
myself and the rest of us who called
ourselves at that time the five lepers
because of the authorization that we
were getting on the inside of the
company like he mentioned people not
facing us as we were walking down the
court is an other such things we tried
to still turn things around internal the
Morton Thiokol because the morale was at
the basement level because the guys that
had made the decision was still in the
same management organizational positions
that they were in when they made that
decision and so we asked for a meeting
with the CEO the president of the
shuttle program at that time and the
president of the aerospace operations of
that company and we failed we basically
failed and then that was another another
stake if you will driven in to me at
that time because the CEO turned to me
he was this close and after my remarks
he said son you're never going to get
very far in this company with that kind
of attitude and all he went to do was to
tell him that his company was crumbling
around his shoulders and he didn't even
know it because they never took time to
go down at the employee level and find
out how bad things were and that's all
we were trying to do and yet that's the
kind of response we got at that point in
time I felt it's all over and it was
just about a month after that that it
was indeed all over well one thing that
came through in your talk was the
loyalty you fell
Tord apparently many of the companies
most of the companies that you were with
I'm wondering if in fact I'm reading
something into your statement in having
the feeling that you probably were
motivated by having the feeling you were
doing the best thing by your company I
felt that night I felt after it I still
feel today you know with every fiber of
life in my body that I was a more loyal
employee at Morton Thiokol in other
places for doing what I had done then
employees who would turn their back and
say nothing that case about the missile
there were many cases on that missile
that there were too numerous to mention
all the time I did the same types of
things and you know I had a very
fruitful career albeit adversarial at
some times but it was fruitful
nonetheless and I do I feel that you
have an obligation to be loyal to your
organizational chain of command and
first approached them first
orally then in writing before you ever
even think about going outside if you
don't do that you deserve everything you
get as an individual for going outside
first because you did not give them the
opportunity you old that company that
loyalty and I have almost felt that even
before I read about all this was the
blowing stuff and I've always felt that
in my heart I didn't know that I was
doing things right down the line like
that's supposed to be done I just felt
that that's the way to do it I have
questions for you too it's better to ask
questions than to receive but it seems
to me that the civil engineers are a bit
different than than other engineers
basic definition though that I've heard
of civil engineers is they build very
large things that don't move and you
want to make sure that they don't move
implying safety considerations and I've
rarely seen a civil engineer who gets
into trouble because he brings up a
safety consideration I mean the earliest
part of our training is watching a film
loop of the Tacoma Narrows Bridge the
galloping gertie you know and they show
that to you over over again and the the
messages don't let this happen to you
but in fact people who work in the
public sector or public sector
engineering run into different types of
ethical issues and the basic ethical
issues are are really relate to values
too because very often you are in fact
society's engineers in society does not
speak with one voice Society speaks in a
very confusing way and there are major
parts of society that in fact don't have
a voice at all and the questions that
are raised you have to do between this
dichotomy between these things you mean
particularly in the environmental area
or in state the transportation area and
all of our young engineers can design
the bridges and pavements of an
interstate highway system yet has
anybody ever asked about the decision
for an interstate highway system and how
that has changed the basic fabric of
America I mean it really has when we
look at the Superfund cleanup which is
of course tremendously interest to us no
one wants to see hazardous and toxic
toxic wastes around in fact we have been
unable so far to define how clean is
clean we simply don't have the
scientific knowledge nonetheless we
can't wait until we have that knowledge
to continue and so we have tried to
bring a veneer of quantification in
something is clean that's and something
that's hardly large and that is not
clean we have a whole ethic built up now
of doing environmental impact statements
for new procedures which somehow is
supposed to represent a valid decision
process yeah the young employee might
question how well it does we have the
growing of environmental terrorists who
have gotten tired of the way
environmental things are going and are
simply taking matters into their own
hands much in the same way of animal
rights activist so I guess the two
questions I would ask you in in this
context and and really come back to your
question is is is how does one deal in
this dichotomy of lining up your own
personal values with society's values
when they're not well represented and
the second question is I would
I would come back to a question that you
raised what is the definition of a
rewarding career when technical analysis
and being good and technical analysis on
certain parts of the problem often does
not address the whole problem well okay
first let me have a little preamble to
the difference between your area in the
area that I functioned in we have a
awful paradox that exists in this
country at this time the people who
build our bridges our roads and our
buildings of the civil engineers who a
licensed engine is they have a code of
ethics they have backing they have all
the things that we don't have in the
industry that I was in people that
builds your automobiles that go over
those roads the planes that you fly in
on a daily basis which I was involved in
the missiles and in the spacecraft are
not licensed people by and large you
don't have to be in so most aren't right
there is part of the root cause of why I
suggest everybody to become licensed
whether it's required or not because I
firmly believe that you could pull that
in as far as a rewarding career is
concerned I defined my career as
rewarding because I was able to make a
lot of corrective actions I was able to
earn a very good living I was very able
and willing to tell him to stick it in
their ear when it became and him pass
and leave
sometimes I changed it was a personal
decision that had nothing to do with a
job but I felt I had the opportunity in
in a general sense in an in a high sense
actually in the 27 years to participate
in a reasonably high level of
engineering activity and to do the very
best I could
whether they wanted me to participate in
that manner or not and so for me by my
personal definition I was allowed to do
most of the things that I was able to do
well because I forced the issue to do it
that way I often found myself wandering
in the shop often found myself wandering
on the test lab often found myself in
places where people like me don't
normally go and so I made it rewarding
in the sense that I did those types of
things and that's why
the reasons I recommended to students to
do the same types of things because you
can get the whole circle closed of
experience you get to not only look at
the specifications design and analyze
test go out and shop see it built and
then follow up with the customer but if
you only focus on the one area you don't
get that that that satisfaction that
feedback loop and that next step of
experience to carry on to the next place
of the next project and so that's how I
define the rewarding career now the
first part of your question you'll have
to repeat for me but I'm not sure I have
to I can grasp the total significance
what you're asked I guess once one moves
beyond safety to another set of values
for instance there are engineers who
work on oh okay work on transportation
systems and technically designed them
very well but in fact they're not there
in the process they're changing the
basic fabric of America engineers who
are working on the environmental impact
statements doing wonderful models of
groundwater but in fact missing other
parts of the problem because one can do
analysis on that now there are major
non-technical value issues I've seen
major reservoir systems designed in in
developing countries which will involve
moving millions of people just to build
the reservoirs and these people at the
lowest economic level and they will
their complete societal fabric will be
disrupted no one speaks for those people
and to a certain extent a young engineer
where he to try and speak for those
people to address those large issues and
it has no forum has no ability it's not
part of it according to people it's not
part of engineering there's no way to
make that argument so how does one work
in a situation like that gingerly I
honestly don't know there it's like you
say there are no mechanisms for that to
occur and even if there was a tiny
mechanism it it's not a significant
mechanism for the big picture go about
to occur you end up becoming a majority
of one you
easily I don't know how to answer that
question do you think do you think that
that young engineers that there's
something missing in their educational
process that that makes them afraid to
stand up in tough situations or is it a
sense of values I mean what why is it
that you had bosses who in fact wanted
to cut the line one who knew something
was wrong but wanted to cover it up is
that is that an educational problem or
is it something about how people move up
in systems I think I think it's an
educational problem but not in the sense
that you view it it's not what you're
taught but what the people have observed
our government and our companies have
done a marvelous job in this country of
making sure that everybody in this
country knows that when you stand up for
cause that's right you're gonna get
creamed and they may that's the first
thing they do if you think back you
think back in every visible thing that
you've read about in recent times and
not one company or one agency has ever
addressed the issue for which has been
brought out
they've always addressed the person and
have absolutely decimated the person and
never discussed the issue and so the
message comes home just by reading about
it that you're going to pay a very bad
price in the norm if you go and do
something like this and so it becomes a
focal point in many people's lives my
boss and Arnie Thompson's boss was the
same man he was a Reggie is a registered
professional engineer he sat in those
meetings he went to Washington and heard
the Presidential Commission hearings
along with us he never said a word in
the meetings before the launch he never
said a word to the Presidential
Commission every night if I had had a
license I think and I hoped I would have
gone a step further and threatened them
with my code of ethics and that's one of
the reasons I'm advising and hoping that
the young people will pick me up on my
challenge is so they can bring that code
into the management however side by the
side or back door it's done maybe
they'll listen I don't know that they
will but maybe they will and I have to
tell you I knew all of these gentlemen
in that meeting prior to this I've had
workings with him for five and a half
years and I have no doubt that when the
general manager said in about halfway
through that caucus am I the only one
that wants to fly I have no doubt in my
mind that if any of the three managers
had said I don't want to fly that he
would have folded his briefcase and
packed it in and gone home no doubt in
my mind he was looking for support from
those guys now that you're on sapote the
enemy side you've taken the other side I
don't understand my colleagues would say
the same thing what's happened and the
only thing we've ever been able to
conclude amongst ourselves was after
attaining this level hunter you have to
protect it well I was promoted to
project engineering manager at thiokol
but I didn't tell you in my short
presentation that after 13 months I gave
it up
I could no longer exist in that I don't
know the word awful organization I mean
they knew nothing about how to manage
two people they could care less about
how it was done and I didn't want to be
a part of it so I went down as a
technical specialist to the manager of
Applied mechanics because I felt I could
help to program the most the company the
most and have the most satisfaction in
my job and says just doing this me do to
mediocre crap day after day after day
and so I gave up a manager of position
and people around me was shocked he said
do you realize what you've done I used
to have a ceiling of $75,000 and when I
did that I lost the substantial amount
of ceiling I think here I want a
day-to-day satisfaction I wanted to do
something in my job but that doesn't
make me a hero it just makes me kind of
unique I guess in one respect because
most people don't think that way
after you get a management position
you're gonna preserve it at all costs
and I didn't do that and I thought there
are the people that did the same types
of thing - I know
unique in that respect I've seen other
people do it but by and large when a
person has attained a certain level
there first and foremost priority
becomes preservation I've seen it in the
27 years I can't believe it I can't
explain why but that happens I think
we're ready to open the floor for
questions so if you those of you with
questions will go to the microphone
then we can have your questions recorded
on on our videotape you mentioned the
meeting at with the air force I think it
was at which your manager gave the
slanted presentation and you said in
silence I think you didn't say anything
to contradict what he said I would
imagine that the air force people they
are interpreting your presence at least
as implicit support for what your
manager was saying is that true well let
me tell you it really in all honesty
didn't matter what he said because the
part had already been designed as a
physical part it had already been tested
as a physical part it worked just fine
but he was trying to puff up a certain
section of an analysis conclusion that
just wasn't so and he wanted me to do
that okay and so I let him do his thing
but I would have shot him down but
regardless of what he said he wasn't
going to change the fact that the part
was good the design had already been
proven in tests and had already been
installed and was going to be used and
so it this wasn't this wasn't a threat
that this was a this was an issue
between him forcing me to do something
that I knew was wrong and I wouldn't do
it and the outcome was absolutely had
nothing doing
excuse me are you talking about the his
earlier event that worked out well in
the long run are you talking about the
telecom the night before the challenge
he's got it right yeah no yeah you talk
I know what yeah you're talking about
the yeah the analysis just curious if
you're satisfied I'm looking back on
that with with from a ethical point of
view with your response to that
I mean silence I mean sitting and saying
nothing I could be considered a deceit
deceiving in some way well keep in mind
though as an individual yeah it doesn't
make a whole lot of sense to me and
maybe I'm wrong but to me it does make a
lot of sense to speak up and serve
yourself up as a sacrificial lamb if you
don't have even a tiny tiny chance of
making a change or effecting a change
and and so in if it if it's not going to
result in any calm downstream or make
any difference what's the point okay so
when it did ya know if it if it had been
a different circumstance and something
was on the verge of failing aho he would
not have given that presentation I
assure you I would have told him I was
going to give that presentation like he
wanted and then proceeded to give it the
way I wanted good evening I'm registered
in Canada as professional engineer and I
haven't bothered to transfer my
registration down here largely because I
see the profile of professional engineer
in the United States just hasn't
attained the status of a Canadian
professional engineer I was wearing you
I fully agree with you that registering
is a darn good thing to do but my
question is what do you suppose we can
do as engineers to raise the profile of
the professional the registered
professional I think they're they're
starting to do just that in the NSPE
and I think you're right they kind of
went along at a mediocre level for years
and I think that they are starting to
come to grips with that I think some of
the professional societies or the
technical societies really where it
needs to start to take place and feed
into the NSPE the technical societies
have got to stop serving the industry
and the underpinning resources they get
from industry and start to serve their
members and I think you're going to see
a chain reaction spill
over into the professional side through
the NSPE but I I saw the NSPE
as a very passive organisation years ago
and I see it as a much more productive
and active organization today for
instance I I met a colleague in Missouri
who was on the board at Missouri when
the Hyatt Regency failure occurred and
they actually pursued that prosecution
of that firm in that engineer is for
blatant screw-ups I mean it was freshman
would not have designed those pins the
way that pin was designed and they've
lost their license and I'll tell you he
told me he took tremendous flack through
the profession for doing what he did
because he was the president of the
Missouri Board at that time and that's
an indication that it started also the
other indication had started and it's
starting really in the civil arena is
because the registration is the
strongest in the civil arena and in this
in the civil area
arena they've put out a product called
quality and the constructed project it's
a manual and it is currently in practice
right now being used under under actual
conditions for review and comment and it
is due to end perhaps at the end of this
year and then they will update that and
expand and put more manuals in but that
is a a wonderful step and that is
feeding in through the NSPE and I think
that's going to go a long way to address
the past moderation that was in that in
that group and the civils are taking the
lead position no question about it
no I don't agree that nothing has
changed it's gotten a lot worse it in
the last 30 years I have witnessed an
unbelievable decline in open chasm
between the technical people in the
managerial side and that it has actually
came about as I observed when I entered
the profession in 1960 the think-tank
groups were implementing a program which
we used to call internally as charm
courses those of us who didn't attend
them call them charm courses and what
these courses were were three to five
day concentrated courses that showed
management how to extract the maximum
amount of profit from an organization
regardless and never look at the
consequences to that organization or the
people in that organization or they or
that or the decrease in morale and stuff
like that and through that period of
time from about 1960 through the middle
70s it just became obvious and just
employees were no longer the resource
precious resource and I referred to him
as a renewable resource and they that's
exactly what they became a source of
labor pool without any regard to the
humanization and and the chasm between
the technical people and the manager if
it's people opened up much much widely
than it was when I was first when I was
first there there was I thought there
was a purpose and the purpose was
towards putting out a good product a
quality product a safe product
on time at a competitive price on a
teamwork basis we used to always check
one another's work there is no checking
done and hasn't been done since
approximately 1970 or even the late 60s
very I don't know of any company that
has the technical people check one those
work
and so the interest is very obvious the
obvious interest is to get something out
the door to get money back in keep the
pipeline filled everybody at the top
smiles and staff it's as simple as that
I mean that's oversimplification but
that's the bottom line
problem one question I'd like to ask
about that because one of the things
that we see the 273 students have been
interviewing companies over the last few
years and a lot of them have made within
the last or I should say seven years
they've made major changes and they put
in ombudsman they put in mechanisms to
be more responsive and even if we say
that some of that is window dressing I'd
be interested to find out how people see
things going because I've been impressed
that at least at some corporations
things have gotten much better I
subscribe to that I I know of several
corporations with sure knowledge that it
it is working it has been implemented
and is great but unfortunately at most
of them they're there in a learning
process and all fairness first of all
you have to give them credit for first
first of all recognizing that they have
a problem can't correct anything unless
you recognize you have a problem and
almost all of them have recognized that
now you have to segregate those that
recognize they have a problem and truly
want to fix it and do something about it
versus those that want to just
superficially fix it and do something
about it and I think we're we're in that
muddled area right now whereas some are
truly fixing and some aren't really
fixing case in point as a result of
Presidential Commission investigation
NASA was to set up a reporting system
that people could report problems
through the organization to a separate
organization and remain totally
autonomous and not be identified that
system was immediately destroyed as
several very diligent people used that
system and found out that they their
names were blurted out all over the
place it killed the effective
effectiveness of that system right out
of the chute and that system is is just
a front now and so you have those and
you have those that are working
moderately and you have those that are
working well and I
to say and that's why I've made in my
comment from my observation that I
believe but most all the companies
recognize they're in serious competitive
trouble in our world marketplace and
productivity as a rock-bottom low and
that they have to do something about it
and they they are putting these in place
and unfortunately I don't have any more
insight than that by observation pretty
you might have well I tend to agree with
you I the mechanisms that companies are
putting in place it's in most cases it
is window dressing it is too little too
late and the fundamental concept of
empowering employees to speak up and to
use that information to change decisions
as well as decision making structures
when it gets to that critical point
that's when companies back down so that
you know certain kinds of suggestions
certain kinds of changes in production
processes in how business is done will
be accepted through those channels
things that question fundamentally the
way the organization is structured which
may be causing some of the problems are
not admissible and I think just sort of
to be fair there's a there is a larger
context going on here I mean you know
CEOs talk about the pressure put on them
by their boards of directors by the
shareholders because of the power that
the Wall Street analysts wield and that
they are held only the short term short
term earnings which leads to short-term
thinking so I think we're we've got a
much more complicated problem here yes I
have a question for mr. Bruce Lee and a
question for the panel question for mr.
Bruce Lee is about your journal could
you describe when you decided to start
writing a journal and why
I virtually never documented anything
except in the memo format that I
explained to you and what was happening
is that the problems were getting so bad
that and I was getting so afraid see
people think it was just a low
temperature problem I was afraid after
the summer of 1985 to launch at all and
that's why I wrote my memo and I started
to document everything in actually
filled for these spiral-wound notebooks
with my documentation
I had a daily log because of the fear of
what was happening and that there would
be no record other than a verbal record
to go back to if something happened and
that's really why I did it the second
question is given that that framework
that you described was destroyed do any
of the panelists have suggestions on how
you would create such a framework
whether it was through the professional
engineers or some other organization
given that it doesn't work apparently
now I mean about the particular status
of the engineer and yeah how the
feedback mechanism could be done I guess
I don't I don't totally agree with mr.
Beaujolais I think that there are times
when when engineering management wants
things that are that are probably good
and engineers don't want to give it to
them well I mean I see numerous
instances where engineers want the
technical challenge and a new job of
redesigning something when in fact they
have something that works and that could
immediately be adapted and but they want
the technical challenge so so these
these terrible engineering managers are
trying to get more productivity and
sometimes they have good reason to ask
for it in the engineering
really wants their sense of a rewarding
career which is to do reanalysis to
start all over again and very often come
up with things that need to be tested
again and they reinvent the wheel but
then there's another part of it which is
the safety human values thing where in
fact engineering management and a
short-term philosophy just acting
diametrically opposed to public safety
and to employee right so I this this
movement of an engineer from technical
to a management line is never easy the
people who tend to follow it are they're
often the more the more the less
technically happy in the more management
oriented they see more money to be
gained in these sorts of things and
they're under they're under a lot of
pressures not all of which are bad
pressures to begin with but coming back
to you your question about what happens
to the role and the status of
technologists I mean there's no it's no
surprise that the number of people in
the United States who want to go into
technical careers is going down we're
finding the biggest recruiter of of our
undergraduates to be the big aid
accounting firms now who want the strong
analytic abilities and the ability to
move these people into finance that's
where the action is that's where the
immediate money is that's where there is
less one has to pay less of a price for
education and get greater rewards what
are we doing to counter this I think we
we haven't given much recognition to the
importance of technology I don't see how
that's gonna turn around it starts in
the high schools look at the look at the
level of science and mathematical role
models and teachers in high schools it's
just simply not there so to a certain
extent engineers Erzberg are defeating
themselves because they're not even
bringing people into the pipeline
they're not making the pipeline look
attractive and and this country is
paying for that
Jim did you want to speak to well I was
going to pick up on something that was
inherent to the two remarks and that is
this feeling that some of us have that
the engineering culture would be well
transplanted into the managerial scheme
of things that if engineers turned into
managers it might be good for a
management we put things in a rather
negative light do you disagree with that
no I think some of the better manages
had come from the engineering ranks but
unfortunately the pressures of the
business side of it made them change
their allegiance but as far as one of
the best managers at Morton Thiokol for
instance was Al McDonald al McDonald is
the guy that actually pulled the
redesign back together because the other
company managers couldn't do it right in
the middle of the redesign to return to
flight they fell flat in their face and
they had to actually call on him to
straighten it out and his engineering
expertise is what allowed him to do that
and his way he thought allowed to do
that so if you could combine the two I
think you get a an excellent result for
person who really cares person has
product and company and customer at the
foremost position and goal of his task I
think you get a terrific marriage
when you do that type of thing
yes mr. Beaujolais you mentioned that in
a number of the ethical decisions that
you had to make the consequences of them
were severe somebody's life was at risk
and what my question is is how much do
the consequences play in your decision
of whether to go to do the ethical thing
for a number of us will be an
engineering fit will be in engineering
fields that weren't necessarily have
those kinds of severe risks like perhaps
you're degrading an error rate on an IBM
disk drive or something well yeah I
mentioned some of the more visible
things but there were a whole host of
things that I didn't mention that were
not only not life-threatening they were
not even product that threatening or
anything threatening period but they
were just the wrong thing to do I don't
mean that from a judgmental standpoint I
for instance there was a part that was
stalled backwards on a missile it was a
band and it was formed as a hoop it was
a very critical part it cost about $25
they wanted to take that and reform it
and reverse the hoop and put it back on
the missile oh it just so happens I was
on the site at the time and I didn't
want them to do that I didn't even want
to spend the time running an analysis
showing whether it was good or not it
wasn't worth the hassle $25 is not worth
ruining $800,000 worth of equipment and
they wanted to put it back in stores and
markets crap and I said well you know I
don't to myself I don't trust you would
you please let me have the part I took
the part folded in half put on the
ground stepped on it it was totally non
usable at that point they went
absolutely wild when I did that and said
they were going to file a grievance and
they were going to take me up to all
kinds of management on this I said fine
let's go nothing ever came of that and
so that that was totally non-threatening
totally not anything and I've had many
of those types of things too it's just
it doesn't make sense to
multi-million dollar systems for 25 and
30 dollar pieces it's just not worth
fussing with and if you know there's
something wrong something's been done
wrong just take care of it on on an
aside issue that's all so I'm just the
way I am on everything first of all I
apologize for being very late this
wasn't advertised and I had no idea this
wonderful meeting was going on but I'm
glad I'm here anyway and I'd like to ask
a couple of questions the first one
relates to the statement made that
there's no point in sacrificing yourself
if it can't make a difference and there
have been a number of statements we've
heard which talk in terms of trade off
is is it worth doing this in terms of
the consequences we'll get and one of my
major problems with the engineering
field as a whole is the way in which it
tends to operate in a consequentialist
vein philosophers today almost all of
them would say that consequentialist
ways of thinking are highly
unsatisfactory and the community of
philosophers has increasingly been
emphasizing issues of rights
what is the right thing to do whatever
the consequences if something is truth
should I not say that truth whatever
will happen to me as a result should I
simply shirk that responsibility because
I don't think it will make a difference
shouldn't one not go for justice
whatever the consequences and I think
that's the fundamental point and I think
it comes not just into everyday
decisions which engineer's make but I
think it also comes into the methods
which engineers use because quantitative
techniques by their definition are
calculated and look at trade-offs and
look at consequences and look at the
best for whatever the problem happens to
be whereas perhaps a more satisfactory
approach would be to say not what is the
best under these certain constraints but
what question should we be asking what
is the best what is the right way to do
our analysis so I'd like you to address
this issue of a consequentialist way of
thinking
and a right way of thinking well first
of all if you acted that way in a purist
sense there would be knowing no one in
the industry cranking out anything for
anybody because the system is so broken
with regard to those types of things in
general that if or everybody come forth
with every issue regardless of their Co
the consequence could be nobody working
because they'd all be out of jobs I know
that sounds very drastic but that's the
way it is if everybody came through not
to be around another day to fight for
the overall thing you'd have nobody
working I beg to differ I think that the
scenario is one between people behaving
as machines in which they're using
standard techniques standard procedures
slotted into some big bureaucratic
mechanism and people who are taking
responsibility for the work which
they're doing have you worked in
industry I certainly have in the
aerospace industry a very large scale
case and so I have some some experience
of these questions and I was quite
satisfied with my decision to protest
what I regarded as an unethical form of
computer modeling even though it seemed
to me but I had no chance of doing
anything about it at that time and I was
not satisfied with doing my job and
carrying on doing computations when I
found that that was what I regard as an
unethical immoral situation and I tried
to influence the people in the place
where I was working to try and and take
this this larger view I think one can of
course both do work and one can think
about it at the same time I think where
engineering falls down there is the lack
of thinking furthermore I think that
what we need educationally is more
training in how to think I frankly
despair as I go through the corridors
here and see the advertisements for this
new ethics course here which which ask
questions about what I regard is
somewhat obvious questions should one
make a product that is unsafe well the
answer to me is no I mean I
that's as far as it goes and perhaps
there are some things to discuss around
that but that doesn't seem to be the
most important point the most important
point seems to be what product should we
be making what method should we be using
what do our techniques imply what should
they imply how should we do that which
is good and just and our basic failure
is is a failure to confront issues of
justice and I think the profession would
be improved if we started on that basis
and I think good work could still be
done within that framework well I agree
but you know aren't you presupposing
that the person at the operational level
low level has the authority and power to
do what you just said it doesn't exist
you're not given the freedoms that you
just mentioned in fact the redesign
case in point on the shuttle program was
not designed by the working engineer it
was designed and redesigned by the
managers and it was up to the individual
engineers to make it work so they didn't
even have the freedom to come up with
the ideas we had plenty of ideas we had
27 concepts that was summarily dismissed
so when you're working the framework oh
not even be allowed to do something like
that you don't you don't have a prayer
out of the chute ah but if you start
from the position of insisting on asking
these questions you can compare yourself
to do these things if as a group we all
force ourselves to do what we thought
was ethically correct and go for those
larger issues we would be able to to
have some influence one of the things
which made me despair the most where I
worked was how the majority of the other
technical people just went and did what
they were told and I often had
subversive little tours around the floor
I worked on and said to people look if
only all of us discuss these issues and
made them known to management then we
would have an effect we shouldn't allow
ourselves to be machines we should be
part of the major decision operators
okay I made that point in my
presentation that one of the first
things you should do is go get Cola go
support first verbally then in writing
and so I I guess I'm agreeing I think we
have another question over here
Oh
[Music]
but a serious mistake a serious mistake
to say that because of technology people
the endless simply is not
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I guess only one comment and I
agree with with significant product what
you say but in in in another sense I
disagree because how can you explain the
total destruction of the work ethic in
this country if you don't lay it at the
feet of the people who are charged with
running the corporate structure that's
responsible for doing this we are no
longer as the United States able to
compete in a world economy because of
this situation they've focused on
short-term profits that they almost told
exclusion of everything else and then
they are responsible for that I've seen
it in my own industry
I watched it happened and I agree with
you to a person nobody openly wants
somebody to get killed nobody openly
plans on something feeling I agree with
you but they at the top never go down on
the floor and kick the tires and find
out what's going on at the low level and
it's not all their fault with regard to
what they make the decisions on because
the corollary to that is that the bad
news gets filtered out so badly on the
way up that they get the impression that
everything as well and in 27 years I've
never understood why a CEO if he did not
have the time because the pressing needs
at his level did not find a confident to
go down and kick the tires for him and
report back to him or her and they've
never done that I have never understood
that philosophy because their companies
generally are coming down around their
necks and they don't even know about it
we are not competing in the world
economy not because we don't have the
talent not because we don't have the
people or the technology we do not have
work productivity within that
rame work anymore and that's the
unfortunate consequence of what has
happened and so I just want to interject
that part of it I think we're going to
have to end because we're 15 minutes
actually over our time I would hope that
you would come to those of you who are
in 273 Roger will be in class on
Wednesday and those of you who are not
could come on one on Tuesday to e25 111
and have further discussion acto at one
o'clock and have further discussion on
these issues
[Applause]